it's out
hello good evening good morning good
afternoon wherever the hell you are in
the world and welcome to Sidetrack your
Sci-Fi TV and Movie Channel live
how are we gentlemen
doing good you're talking to me when you
use gentlemen wow thanks
no no I was just talking to the Easter
in general so I'm just saying being
considered a gentleman is you know rare
for me
thank you
I call everybody sir okay I get I get
grief for it sometimes everyone's either
sir or Bud for me and those are my two
go-to's all right bud how do you see it
that's that's it anyway
um yeah I'm good man I'm good
um let's get into it before we uh lose
our minds so we got a little bit of news
I dropped in the week so but we're gonna
do the news like Fox News now because
we're just actually going to do pure
opinion and it's not based on anything
actually like concrete so yeah
Fox News
foreign
[Music]
gotta use the obviously bit so anyway I
dropped the news in the week that one of
my sources messaged me saying when you
did your sgv SGU video talking about how
they would say the destiny why didn't
you bring up what Mark Fergus said in
that marketing meeting or that um
development meeting uh nine months ago
and I went because I don't know what
Mark Fergus said in the development
meeting a moments ago and anyway an
argument ensued
um and I pointed out but anyway he
basically came up with the idea that the
destiny would eventually be saved by the
planet Builders who we actually don't
even know were real or not but
he said you know that it was Joseph
malozi actually came out said that they
were going to appear a lot in the third
season if they'd got one I just wondered
what you guys thought about that idea
um and you know he didn't really put any
meat on those bones so we we have to you
know fill in the gaps a little bit but
what do you generally think about that
idea before we go into the this week's
video
sense
uh that they would probably have went
down I don't know I'm in two minds with
that it's a it makes sense that that's
quite a logical way for them to get home
because it's like a malevolent
species are super super Advanced but I
think it's a bit of a cop-out
because it's a malevolent species
helping out rather than they just got
home on their own is it too easy yeah I
think probably but it would be
interesting to see the way I liked is
that he said that he was going to
basically Rush was going to have to have
like a moral dilemma he was Rush was
basically going to be in the option is
that you can either find out what the
mysterious message in the background
radiation was or you can go home but you
can't do both
so it was going to be but it was like
going to be like a test a bit like q and
Star Trek which we're going to be
talking about in a minute what do you
think about that Aaron I think is that a
test he would have succeeded with or
would he just gone nah I just want to
know what the message was
uh he definitely would have taken more
time than most people would have thought
he should take with that decision I can
guarantee that much
um
as for
like Matt said I think it makes the most
sense I don't know
the level to which it's a cop-out really
depends I think on what the plan is for
you know the future like
if they need them home quicker for
storyline then you know that's cool
but uh you know I guess it really
depends on their agenda but yeah it is a
it is a bit too easy
I can agree that's a bit too easy but on
the other hand you may need to you know
in order to get the story moving you may
need to move that part along so you can
get to the rest of it just a little more
quickly and if we do get a continuation
or a result of SGU it's not going to be
a series it's not going to be two or
three series like a lot of people want
it's going to be
maybe a couple hour s special or a
mid-season thing or maybe an overrated
story arc is probably something else in
one to ten episodes you know it's not
it's not gonna be more than that but
anyway I'm just wondering what you guys
thought about it because I actually
thought like I said I I think it's a bit
easy I liked the idea that um the planet
Builders weren't actually the guys that
sent the message but they were a race of
people that Millennia ago had gone
searching for it and had like I I said
it's like they'd touch the face of God
in the in the video
um and I I like that because it's a
little bit of a Twist on it maybe but
yeah that was interesting and again it's
just these ideas coming off Mark
fergus's head but it's nice to again see
a little bit of an insight into what
he's thinking about if this is the guy
that then takes on the story and I just
love that that was done with no
preparation it was a development chat
and he just started spitting spinning
these things off top of his head I just
think that gives me more confidence that
if he is the guy that finally gets the
the development gig sort of thing that
he actually knows what he's talking
about so yeah I think it's it
it if it's a series now
it might not actually be that much of a
bad idea because they want to wrap up
his dude they want to wrap up all the
Loose Ends and then kick start something
new so the being too easy part
doesn't really matter
thinking about it because they just want
to they just want a way for them to get
home that's a pretty good way which ties
back to a story that we've already seen
in the previous season anyway so it's
within Canon
and it could lead into so many other
things as well it could be a small part
of a much bigger story couldn't it as
well
quite easy they could investigate who
are these aliens maybe they'll then
Destiny but they'll try to
explore who they are because they they
might not they might be Galaxy span uh
multi-galaxy spanning species
like the Ancients they're ascended but
they're only ascended within the Milky
Way order only ascended Within
um Pegasus these might be
slightly higher but they span multiple
multiple galaxies and that would be an
interesting story to explore something
beyond the Ancients who I I think would
be interesting Joseph and Lucy talked
about them maybe not being as
technologically advanced
as we thought but I like the idea of
something maybe not an ideological but
but spiritually they're further along or
something like that but but they're more
though or they're different at least to
the Ancients but in a same way anyway
like nice let's um go back and let's do
the proper topic
[Music]
right so we are doing I we did like a
statement episode of video last week
didn't we where I did a bunch of
statements and we just basically picking
about it by the way we don't know where
Harris is
a young man I'm probably he's probably
unconscious somewhere but
um but you never know he might be along
with us at some point so um so we're
going to do like a series of statement
it's based on this episode that in five
years Stargate will be a bigger
franchise than Star Trek
first of all do you agree or disagree
with that statement before we argue it
just I completely disagree as much as I
would love Star Trek Stargate Stargate
to be the bigger franchise I'll go into
reasons why but I don't think it will
it's it can't it can't at this point I
don't think
how about you Aaron
agree or disagree I
I actually think it's possible it
depends on
it depends on a little bit of timing and
it depends on a couple other things
happening a couple other franchises but
I definitely think it's within the realm
of possibility they're
they're definitely um
what's the word I'm looking for I guess
I'll use conditions it's not the one I
want to want it but maybe we're going to
discuss through the video but there are
less but a lot of inputs but I I don't
think it's I don't not only do I not
think it's impossible I don't even think
it's outside the realm of possibility I
I would give it an above 50 chance of
happening again
I'm going to agree with the statement
but I'm going to agree with the base
statement based on the thing that I I
think there's a
good to reasonable possibility the Star
Trek or anything on our screens in five
years time but again we'll talk about
that anything so it'll win by default my
two favorite words default default
so right okay so the first statement
we're going to discuss Star Trek has
more stories to tell and it's a bigger
Universe to explore than Stargate
discuss
no
why
um
as far as I know Star Trek is still
limited to our galaxy stargate's already
been to two others
um which gives them a few times as well
but not as often the universe yeah there
was no episode
where the the engineer came on in the
original not an original song
and they just got sent like yeah it's
been so long since I've watched that of
those episodes but okay I forgot about
that one okay but that was accidental
yeah did it on purpose or purposefully
Galaxy hopping to see what they can find
which statistically at least gives them
many more species and
Mysteries and all kinds of fun crap
potentially to deal with just based on
statistical probability of Galaxy on me
so
I mean not though I mean there are more
races and more species in Star Trek
there's a lot more and I've got to fly
flying around me and it will die give me
some chopsticks
um right now they do yeah
yeah but Matt we don't see that many
races really in Stargate do we I think
we see just enough in Stargate for it to
make the story make sense
there's not too many there's not too
little we have just enough
in Stargate that it makes
the story made sense like we it's a
story based on
the Asgard in one episode and then the
token and like there are so many
different
species that we do see there the the
universe in story is pretty huge
a lot of them are only one episode
but they still exist yeah the one thing
I would argue with Star Trek is if if
they've got so much story to tell and so
much Universe to explore why do they
keep telling the same story over and
over again
that you know they keep having how many
prequels are we onto now or remakes or
reimaginings
um you know they they Enterprise prequel
and then they went into now now they're
telling the story between you know the
captain pike years
the JJ Abrams remade them and you can
argue Picard has just gotten remade the
Wrath of Khan and before that it remade
the Voyage Home sorry I'm a bit of a
geek when it comes to Chucky they're
remaking the same stories over and over
again so why
if but they've got this massive Universe
stargate's never done that
I'm not gonna say anything until
somebody speaks
um well
depending how much that you're talking
about like a bunch of rehashing of
stories no but following a certain kind
of
template I would say they definitely do
that yeah
but they do adjust the template based on
the kind of story they want to tell
which
is good because otherwise that good
boring AF
every TV show ever pretty much
oh yeah kinda I suppose when you get
down to the ultimate Basics but I think
um
I think the uh the storytelling on the
Star Trek side has definitely gotten
stale and since stargate's been gone for
so long it's it's gonna it's gonna hit
screens
almost like starting Anew since it's
been off since it's been gone for so
long so it's going to be new essentially
new it's going to be fresh it's going to
be something that like we haven't seen
in a decade and
non-gators haven't seen ever
so I think just the just the new shiny
aspect would give it a big boost
you know because everyone loves the new
thing
um
whilst we were talking about that old
gate could be essentially the original
series
TRS and then this would be next
generation
but there's three seasons of original
series like three separate shows
yeah so it doesn't I don't know if it
works
of the original series which didn't
really have a lot of Canon and then the
movie by the time the TNG came along I
think they've done through two or three
movies so yeah
there's a lot more behind Stargate than
there is
when Star Trek became Next Generation
see the one things with Star Trek that
always frustrates me though is that
there is so much story there now there's
so much Canon and it does tread on its
own toes quite a lot which is why JJ
Abrams copped out and went well I've
just time travel through a wormhole uh
no they threw for a black hole somebody
needs to tell that man that you can't
fly through black holes but anyway
um
but it steps on Canon so much and
Stargate never has done but when
Stargate returns that is a massive risk
they've got to really be careful
that they do expand the universe and
they don't try to tell the same stories
because that's what Star Trek is always
pretty much done Discovery prequel
um you know Strange New World prequel
Picard retold the same story from the
movies you know it's just like
Stargates I don't think stargate's
fallen into that trap yet and I actually
think maybe maybe that's one of the
reasons why it failed because SGU tried
to do something different and the fans
their immediate response was
don't like it different uh I
will just point out there was a prequel
it was Origins oh yeah that didn't go
down well
no exactly so there you go this makes my
point beautifully really you know what
I've never seen Origins
you know it's all right it's all right
never watched it
um an hour long it's it's worth a watch
at least I think definitely getting Mark
Fergus is going to be key
because he seems to be the only one that
we've heard about that could potentially
be involved in it that actually
has knowledge and like care of the
franchise I mean Star Trek
almost has that with um
uh who's the dude that did season yes
that guy metallis
um but unfortunately kurtzman keeps
sitting on his head so
uh
I think he's jealous I think it's
genuinely jealous and we're tell us oh
well yeah we're going to talk about ones
in a bit as well but the fans seem to
like to tell us when [__] hates that
of course Ellis came in and turned the
card into what it should have been the
first two seasons and just did it all in
the third
yeah
yeah 100 yeah
all right we'll talk about business then
so Stargate though has Amazon behind it
back in it
Paramount just cannot compete
with Amazon Amazon is a juggernaut does
that make a difference because of
investment the platform that it's going
to be shown on
all of these things that make basically
give Stargate a massive leg up that
really Paramount with just Paramount
plus now where Star Trek goes from now
on
doesn't have
um I don't think it's necessarily a fair
comparison for Amazon saying Amazon and
then Paramount because Amazon as an
entire company so many different
branches of
different companies you've got the
Amazon
um the main one is their fulfillment so
my products stuff like that yeah the
Amazon video all the Amazon Studios
is relatively new
yeah
Paramount probably actually is slightly
above where they are because they've got
the experience they know
like what they they know the business
Amazon is just starting out
this isn't why they bought MGM
yes
but everyone jump ship
well so
so they may they may own MGM
but the people in charge I would say
uh
so I I don't know maybe it's not fair to
say they don't know what they're doing
because they obviously do they've been
working various different companies
before in the past but
the whole thing is is new the whole
thing is relatively the only big the
biggest thing they've done so far is
rings of power
and it didn't didn't do well I thought
it went marvelously
nobody can complain about that marvelous
TV show although saying that they've had
the expanse they've had the boys they've
done tremendously well
mm-hmm
I love the boys but they were brand new
projects they weren't existing existing
projects and that's
I think that's my point um new things
they might be alright with because it's
new it's fresh and then no one's going
into a bit of any expectation
yeah it brings a power there's massive
expectation behind it where Stargate is
going to be even more expectation I
would say well maybe not
a different type of expectation yeah
because the tokenists are um so
detail-orientated that story isn't here
when I said that that's the wrong bloody
colored coke the tolkienists you know go
absolutely berserk or you know his
helmet should have horns
and looks like okay like we don't We're
not gonna have that are we
um but yeah they're insane here's what I
here's what I think um I Matt you do
have a fair point when it comes to the
experience Factor but here's the big
Advantage for MGM slash Prime slash
whatever you want to call it
if they if MGM has a product that Amazon
as a corporation will love all they got
to do is transfer some money from the
Fulfillment
to the to the movie part and they can do
pretty much any damn thing they want and
hire anyone they need to do it
so I think like I mean when it comes
down to it Hollywood is just a big
conglomeration of Corporations anyway
and what's the what's
in the bottom line in any Corporation
it's all about the bengies and Amazon's
got a lot more money than Paramount
and then I think whether they have it in
mgm's accounts right now is a different
story but all they got to do is just you
know call the accounting department and
say hey we need this over here with MGM
because we're gonna do some [__] they're
like okay cool
on we go MGM is it what do you do is MGM
is a business so as MGM is a separate
entity virtually doesn't exist anymore
it's they have completely absorbed MGM
into Prime
um they still have an office
um but apparently there's a bunch of
prime logos everywhere and rhyme people
from Prime their control mostly offices
but the head of MGM is also the head of
um Prime the um Jennifer
[Music]
is also the head of MGM movies so it
that all there is MGM is a massive
stockpile of Ip that now Amazon uh just
going through the toy box
which which toy they're going to play
with first that's it but they've been
such a massive re-jigging of the entire
businesses but at the end of the day
Paramount is about eighth or ninth in
the listing of um streamer Services it's
it's it's one of the smallest streaming
services
um Prime is second
behind Netflix
I always forget that there might be
Disney plus and then Netflix I forget
but it's like Netflix is first the top
three Netflix Disney plus and
um and and and Prime now I know Prime
then uses all of these sub categories so
the Stargate might end up in MGM plus
which would be a nightmare I think if it
airs there and then goes on to Prime
afterwards that's fine but if it stays
on MGM plus that's a disaster
so you think I never understood when
they took over MGM they're gonna have
the entire Library they've already got a
platform why did they need to have I
know they kind of want to be a
conglomerate conglomerate a aggregator
of con of streaming services but
you already have a you have the
infrastructure to host whatever you want
because you own Amazon web server or
Services you have the platform in Amazon
Prime why do you need to create another
one or bring over what they already have
just literally just copy and paste the
library over to Prime you don't need MGM
plus it's you you are the same company
it's basically like
it's like a DLC in a game
an unnecessary DLC like you you want to
play you you want to play the main game
but oh if you want if you want to play
this part of it you need to buy this
this extra
good people do yes yes it's good if I
want all of it if I want to watch one
show
I would I would bet that any money that
when the movie is done which I I
honestly think I'm 95 no that's a bit
much 75 certain they're going to go
cinematic movie
it will then go on Amazon Prime I think
when the TV series comes it's going to
go MGM Plus
um and I think it's stupid but I think
apparently that's one of the things Mark
Fergus was arguing about in December
when they were saying like look this
can't go on Amazon you just wanted
Clarity watch where where is this show
going what are we doing at what platform
is it going on because that really does
affect
budget it affects what sort of show it
affects the tone of the show you know it
matters where is it going to end up I'm
hoping they're going to put in a prime
Premiere and then it'll move to MGM plus
hopefully Bob in the comments is just uh
an interesting comment MGM plus can be
rented out to other streaming services
it already is so that yeah that's quite
interesting if that's that's not I've
not seen that anywhere in the UK
um but if that's it's not how it works
here something that happens elsewhere
where that in the particular platform is
like an add-on to
let's for example say say in in the
context in the UK Sky TV or virgin TV
that would be quite interesting because
then you're not necessarily paying for
Prime as well it is like what we're
getting at the moment it doesn't matter
how I've got Sky TV so I get free
Netflix because it's part of the package
in America they have a lot of that they
have a lot of um you can buy bundles of
streaming services
what Amazon industry trying to do they
want bundles and but basically Amazon
want to get paid twice that's the point
that's what I'm I I don't think is
necessary if
if you're going to pay for if if you
want to watch MGM plus fine pay for MGM
plus but you don't I don't think it's
necessarily a good idea I mean it makes
business sense but it kind of just craps
on the consumer to say you have to pay
for Prime as well even though you might
not want to watch anything that's on
Prime because the Content Library of
prime is way lower than what the Content
Library everything plus is going to be
there's so many so much good stuff
around GM
I can only think of
two shows that I will watch maybe three
on it on Prime and that's Clarkson's
Farm
that's the expanse and that's the boys
yeah maybe popcorn power makes a good
point here with the um they just can't
see I think we've talked about if
there's going to be a cinematic movie
does it make sense I've argued that the
reason why I think they're going to do
it was not just because a couple of
people close to it have told me thinking
this is where we're gonna go and
actually deadline suggested it but the
reason why they're going to go cinematic
is because they've already got the
funding for so many cinematic movers a
year and Jennifer Salk has just gone
well one of those should be stuck it
um I don't think it makes sense from a
franchise point of view and we've talked
about the risk of that but it's money
again they've the money's already been
earmarked for it so Jennifer's Arc is
just like well we may as well use it
yeah I don't know if it's a good thing
it's it's it'll be either amazing for
the franchise
or terrible yeah
if Fergus is involved in the movie side
I know he's probably going to be
involved in the TV so if he's involved
in the movie as well
it could work it could it could be all
right because it can easily transition
then
tell you what you're talking about Star
Trek being the bigger franchise at the
moment could Stargate overtake it
Star Trek hasn't got any movies in
cinemas they're going to make a couple
of straight to Paramount Plus movies but
they're not going to be putting into the
cinema
so straight away I would say the
franchise is the new movies that are
coming out in the next couple years not
going to the cinema then nope straight
to section 31 movies going straight to
streaming on Paramount Plus it's
basically going to be a two-hour episode
okay
well that's that's a that's a positive
for Stargate then more bumps in seats
and Cinemas gets more money in the
pocket of Amazon and more uh
more hype for the franchise yeah and
more credibility I think yeah Hugo
fantasize it in in the cinemas compared
to that's not Star Wars you know you I I
always think if you can get reasonably
successful movies and the TV show
reasonably sexual we're not talking
about Star Trek anymore we're talking
about Star Wars
if they'd have done the Obi-Wan series
as a movie like they originally planned
that would have been done so much better
than it did dude did you hear about the
uh what the uh the scriptwriter said
like when he basically told everyone
what was going to be in it did you hear
any about what was gonna what that was
gonna be like okay I don't give a crap
about Star Wars oh I know you don't but
I brought it up so shut up Jay
[Laughter]
um I do care about Star Wars tell us the
Star Wars story
was still going to be a character in
there but she was going to be so much
more badass like shoot shut up like she
was she was gonna be like adult scarred
from Order 66 I mean she still would
have an obsession with Vader she
wouldn't know he's Anakin she just knows
he's the emperor's Lackey and just wants
to kill his ass anyway and she's still
obsessed with Obi-Wan and
um I think Princess Leia still would
have been involved but it was just a
much better written much better put
together story I'll have to try and find
the article again it was in one of the
trades is it one of those things I think
they just tried to stretch out a basic
story into a series yeah they took them
they took the dude's movie script gave
it to Joby Herald and said turn this
into a six episode show and he failed
yeah
in my opinion I thought it was good but
it would have been way better as a movie
I liked four maybe five scenes total the
rest of it was Googled glob poorly
filmed poorly directed poop
I like the fight that's it's the one
style that's the best moment if people
actually had the force this is what a
fight would look like so it's the first
time I think you've actually had a fight
that makes sense in Star Wars fight
ERS fight when they've thrown rocks at
each other
Weaver fight was dope because he didn't
even pull out his lightsaber he just
threw around with the force a little bit
and then took her saber from her
like he never drew his own sword not
once
but it just shows the power doesn't it
anyway yep right next statement then
because before we get dragged into a
Star Wars chat by Aaron oh no I wasn't
gonna go that far but one more point I
will say is um I think I'm just although
a lot of people will consider this a
trend I think every big franchise or
every IP that people want to make a big
franchise they all need their feige
each and every one of them like Fergus
could be stargate's flag yeah
metallis we want to be Star Treks flagy
but kurtzman's Kathleen Kennedy ass is
always getting in the way yep
notice how there's all these K's are
[__] [__] up sorry your stream not
mine but they're all messages messing
things up terribly terribly messing
things up yeah I think I think nowadays
even though some people will be like oh
that's trendy crap it I I think it's
becoming obvious fact if you look at
where all these IPS are going I mean
Grant and Marvel did have a crappy phase
four but that's because flagy was like
trying to let people take the lead and
now we apparently the rumor is he's
clamped back down and he's gone oh yeah
no he's he like the whole
he walked into the writer's room for cat
form was just like nope this is garbage
this is garbage this is garbage bam
we're doing Red Hulk screw your little
serpent Society crap cause that's as big
as they were gonna go originally it was
just the serpent Society for that um
like the movies that are gonna start to
come out next year you're gonna see
you're gonna see Marvel
switch back to something a lot closer to
phase three simplified as well is one of
the things in that I had that um Frankie
said this is too complicated people
can't follow it and it's a mess
because there's no one person sort of in
control it was just getting confused and
all over the bound shop well the Disney
Plus shows did not help with that at all
because most of them were just kind of
there they none of them really tied into
the overarching Multiverse Saga or
anything like that so but yeah
the TV shows and they're cutting back on
those yeah
Disney plus generally is cutting back
yeah
deemed a big cut back but yeah Marvel's
only gonna be putting out like
three movies and two shows a year I
think or it's two and three of one way
it's two minutes
and three yeah two movies three TV shows
I think yeah either way though but the
main the main point being it whether you
think it's a trendy thing or cliche
thing or not
IPS that you want to be huge franchises
they need that fighty type
so that's what I'm really hoping that uh
Captain I really hope kurtzman like has
a slip and fall and just you know is
stuck at home for six months and
metallis has to run it
well after that I think Coachman would
just do it from his hospital bed but he
thinks that amounts of control freak
anyway next next statement the
characters in Star Trek are iconic
Stargate just doesn't come close I would
agree with that
because of but the reason why I would
have initially disagreed with this that
star Stargate will be bigger than Star
Trek in five years is because Star Trek
is so ingrained in pop culture
everyone knows Star Trek you do you do
hang on or can I do it with this hand
you do that to someone they know what it
is they know it's star they know it's
Star Trek they don't necessarily know
what it means yeah but they they've made
all the Klingons are coming but you've
never seen it before
I mean
everybody knows who Kirk is everybody
knows who Spock is exactly with
um with pop culture like memes come
about from that as well there were so
many memes from from the original series
from the when did that even come out
like the 60s yeah
after 5 to 68 66 69 something like that
a lot of memes even today
have the original series which is
a show that's not been on for decades
but Stargate hasn't been on for just
over a decade and I don't see many
Stargate memes maybe there'll be an
indeed from tilk Maybe
but that's only for people in the know
for Stargate because it's not culturally
known as bigger Star Trek and I hope it
will be one day but I don't think five
years is enough time for that to happen
because Star Trek had so like that
that massive amount of time 60 years to
become ingrained in the pop culture
Stargate hasn't had that yet and
although it was on for
let's say 15 years and it never reached
that level
there were people who I talk to and I
say oh my favorite show is Stargate and
now I've never heard of that yeah and it
was quite big in the UK it was bigger in
the US but it was quite big in the UK
yeah it wasn't massive here's the thing
though
uh when Stargate was originally out we
were just at the Advent of the
information age now we are just smack
dab in the middle of it like anything
happen if something happened in freaking
Malaysia right now we'd all know about
it within five minutes yeah so I I think
the Stargate characters could become
iconic
with given what we got going on now with
the internet fairly quickly I I don't
like before yeah time exposure obviously
With The Star Trek characters and the
Star Wars characters they've all been
around for decades I don't think you
have to be around for decades to become
iconic anymore not not with not with the
way things are not throb in an actor or
or a bit of a you know a bit of a love
triangle going on or something or
something like that to like put yeah
it's a character
Paris Hilton can become culturally
iconic the Stargate characters can
become cultures
I actually agree with you there Aaron
because think about show like stranger
things it's what six years old tops five
years yeah you want to talk about it
that's one of the most iconic TV shows
of our current time yeah and like
exactly so like in today's day and age
it does not take long to become iconic
at all it can happen in a couple months
you get the right actor or actors
and I dare you to tell me MacGyver is
not mutable we bring you anyone sees
Richard Dean Anderson even if he's only
in just the movie or whatever you're
gonna see MacGyver memes flying around
the internet all over again so I mean
our our rda's got that up he's got that
cultural pull because he's been around
since the 80s and MacGyver was flipped
huge I was gonna say just it's similar
to what you've just said as long as they
understand social media
and they understand
how to Hype something up all you need to
do is share one one clip
one really good clip make it go viral
that puts you into relevancy into into
meme status where people will then
recreate it Tick Tock is a good example
of this like something will happen and
then
usually it's just a regular person but
like companies do it as well like
they'll do something and then people
recreate it and it becomes a meme and
then
it just snowballs and then
eventually you don't know where it
actually came from so there is a danger
of that but yeah
yeah they understand it it'll be right
you've always got the rings of power
problem in the Amazon actually generally
thought all the talk about rings of
power is a good thing and it massively
backfired so I mean there is always
there's it's a dangerous game with that
they always used to say there's no no
such thing as bad publicity and now
they've realized in the last two or
three years oh God there is yeah um and
it's that's but I think the one thing I
think about with the iconic characters
thing is I don't necessarily think it's
a good idea I don't think it's sorry
it's not necessarily a good thing
because the problem with Star Trek is
they keep having to re-bring characters
that are iconic back we're now onto our
third Kirk
because uh
third Spock
fourth Spock and but they have to all of
the stories end up being centered around
these iconic characters
and it it damaged the franchise I
honestly think I think stargate's done a
pretty good job with that
in the past obviously we had the four
iconic before before icons uh being Jack
Sam Daniel and tilk
but then they made Stargate Atlantis and
then they had John Taylor Rodney and
Ronan I almost forgot his name then
um and then they went into it they went
to series nine left sg1 yeah and
replaced Jack O'Neil when yeah so
they've already they've already I would
say avoided that trap because and
they've made it work
and Star Wars has a similar problem
iconic things and they keep having to
bring back because the fans go nuts if
you don't everyone's a Skywalker
well
um part of part of it is because they
the new characters are coming up with
they're not writing very well so we want
like our good characters back
if they've been doing if they've been
doing a quality job with like the new
new stuff out outside of the Mandalorian
um I know there's a lot of people
that'll say andor's great and I will
again I'll just acknowledge it's great
TV at Star Wars it's crap
um but it is definitely a well-made TV
show I will give I will give it that
credit
but
um
great I digressed myself out of my
original point
but even with Mandalorian which is
Bitcoin oh yeah I think becoming iconic
is the problem popular is one thing
iconic yeah is a problem I think
sometimes yeah you'll just calling the
Trap of having to use the same
characters over and over and over again
yeah like I If it come back I would
absolutely love them to have completely
new species like don't
some some of the species like the Asgard
and the gold they can they can reappear
but it would be great to have some
actually new
aliens they need to be brave yeah
and they've already kind of solved that
problem because all the Asgard apart
from the veneer who are in Pegasus and
all the grow older dead well yeah all
the system Lords are anyway all the
other ones that are just like scuttering
around
all right so
um
they're overthinking the Stargate
relaunch is uh as your status said and I
would agree with you so actually I
actually don't think that's that I don't
think they're particularly overthinking
it I think there's been lots of
conversations I think the problem is
because of the sources that we've been
able to get through the channel or we've
pretty much known about all the
different conversations and I'm told
that all these conversations are quite
normal
but the difference has been MGM thought
they were getting Stargate and they said
they did loads of prep work and then
Amazon came in and went no you're not
and there was basically a six-month
period where they re-jig the entire
business which we were also in the know
about
so now 18 months has gone by but really
it's just three lots of it's it was six
months with MGM six months reorganizing
and now six months where they're
actually building up getting ready to
actually do it but they're also getting
ready to do a load of other things as
well so it's sort of like it's so it
feels to us like it's taking forever but
on a business point of view until
actually
18 months to two years to develop a TV
show that's perfectly normal
how long are we about rings of power
before it actually hits our screens I
know that's a bit of a that's a
juggernaut of a show but
the days well we know about that a few
years ago yeah exactly the days of green
light though to to air in on a network
it's been six months
doesn't happen anymore it just doesn't
happen so I get load of confidence oh
you keep going on about this because
yeah because this is the process it's
just it's not my fault it's like the
thing with rings of power as well is we
knew about a couple of years ago but
that's before but that's without like
a channel like ours who hears something
without official announcements
so we're saying things that so we would
say for 18 months as long as it's going
to come up and telling the entire
process but then they might be slightly
more
when there's official announcement
um
which might make it feel that longer but
realistically the only reason you know
it's taking this long is because we told
you and you wouldn't have known if we
didn't exist kind of thing yeah so sorry
but we share the news with you as we
hear it
right anyway the next statement new Trek
has been a monster success and Trek has
never been in a stronger position than
it is right now Stargate cannot compete
now if you're an actual Trekkie right
now you'd be Spitting Fire and going
stronger than it's ever been but
um I I will just try to withhold in my
anger at this at this statement that I
wrote
um because what do you think I mean is
Star Trek the most popular it's ever
been
I wouldn't say so I I can't comment on
the the content of the news the new
stuff because I've not watched a lot
I've watched a little bit of strange new
world and I like I really liked it
um
but everything as a whole I can't really
comment on but I wouldn't say it's as
it's as popular as it's ever been
because
you don't I don't know
I feel like I would hear more people
talking about it
in general not just special specialist
channels on YouTube if it was as popular
as it was was back in the day kind of
thing
what do you think Aaron
without seeing actual numbers
um for me personally I feel like Star
Trek and Star Wars are about kind of in
the same boat right now
um both of them
are attempting to expand their IP and
they've had hits and they've had misses
um the fan bases both fan bases have
ended up fairly well divided over how
things have come out and how they've
been written and produced in
all that stuff so
um no I don't think Star Trek is at any
any kind of PowerPoint in its existence
um
I think if
I think one of the biggest differences
is there's so much other stuff to watch
now like you know back when TNG and DS9
and Voyager were out we were still
mostly on broadcast television
completely 100 Netflix didn't exist yeah
our options were a great deal more
limited at that point so
um in today's
content in in today's content landscape
no they're they're nowhere near as
strong as they've been in the past and
without
without more of stuff like changing
worlds in season three they're just
gonna keep going the way of Star Wars I
feel like where they're just gonna be
like oh here's a hit and then oop Miss
Miss oh here's a little bit more in the
you know that kind of thing that's
probably true I mean pecan season three
was the first Star Trek show to ever
appear on the Nielsen top ten so out of
all this out of all of the streaming
shows that week
Picard and it didn't go to number one at
the Nielsen list it went to about number
eight
um so
it was it was the eighth most popular
show on streaming that week you know and
that was a massive success for Star Trek
and at the end of the day as well Picard
season three is just having a success
they're talking maybe about doing the
movie but when
um the Next Generation ended they
started doing cinematic movies
um that was for me that is the height of
Star Trek that was when it was on its
strength because they were strong enough
and popular enough to do cinematic
movies they're not now they want if they
were if they if it was really as popular
as it was then section 31 would be with
Michelle yo would be going straight to
cinema
yeah exactly so and I would also argue
um that the fan base for Star Trek is
massively divided
um there are just as many people that
detest I mean properly hate
new track they really hate it the only
other argument I can say is like if you
start if you start talking about Donald
Trump and Biden that's the only thing
that I've ever seen people get that
upset about yeah
check out some Star Wars chats sometime
dude it's the same same thing I I
actually think Star Wars yeah I think
the fact I don't think the fan base is
quite as divided as Trek at the moment
but but yeah it's actually no thinking
about it it's probably probably right
because I know a lot of people then ever
since Disney took over I joked in my
video last week
that Rogue one is the most interesting
Star Wars video that Disney have ever
done
um and I'm thinking like it's actually
people hate the Disney they don't say
the Disney have ruined it yeah oh yeah
there's there are so many
channels that are just killing it just
coming just coming at all the content
not just Disney but coming at every a
lot of Disney mostly Disney Marvel Star
Wars they are coming at them so hard
from the right and everything is so
right or left now that they host it
those channels are just killing it I
mean obvious that for me they're just oh
yeah oh no
if I started I'd get away more views oh
yeah
when I talk I've talked a bit negatively
about Star Trek only because that's the
negative stuff because it's not just a
fan base that's divided in Our Star Trek
Paramount is divided on Star Trek there
are there are people that Paramount that
hate secret hide it and what they've
done with Star Trek and they think it's
just that they've ruined a perfect
they're ruining a franchise and they're
they're they're worried about it
um and they don't like kurtzman and they
would more than happy would get rid of
him I've shared what I've been told by a
couple of people
um but even then I tried to put a
positive spin on it and I try to keep
the thing I don't like doing negative
stuff but oh you know if I was sat here
I went
Discovery only got only stayed on our
air because it was too expensive to
cancel that was one of the rumors I
heard recently he goes and it's not true
Netflix have got a history that they
will cancel something if it's no good
and the first seasons of Star Trek
Discovery were on Netflix they'd have
gone or something even if it is good
after one season yeah exactly I'm
popular they don't care see see The Dark
Crystal uh age of resistance
their contracts are very Dynamic anyway
we'll put it that way so now Star Trek
isn't the the Juggernaut I think it's
good to see and I honestly think it's
very precarious and I actually genuinely
think
it's only one really bad show away from
just getting canceled again
which goes into my next thing
um
the fatigue Star Trek fatigue is
something that was talked about a lot at
the end of Enterprise so we had a TNG
Voyager Deep Space Nine and Enterprise
and there's a lot of people that just
said look it's not that Enterprise was
bad people just had fatigue they were
just bored of Star Trek it needed a
break if about as long as Target's been
off you know it was off our screens for
a good 10 years
and before it came back and with the new
with a new track Discovery whatever
um after the JJ Abrams success
so
is Stargate is Star Trek really at risk
of that again and is it what actually
killed Stargate
through SGU
maybe I mean I can see the the fatigue
for new track becoming a thing because
there are so many new Star Trek series
I'm a um
TNG that's that's literally the series
I'm on now and it's daunting looking
forward
because of how many new things are
coming out even now so the fatigue now
but yeah I can see it I can I can
definitely see it um with regards to
Stargate
Maybe
I think Atlantis was a good segue into a
new storyline
Stargate Universe
I have always said was slightly a little
bit more ahead of its time so it
probably could have done it would have
done a lot better if it was
five six years later rather than
directly after Atlantis or directly
after yes you want I would say
that's that's probably true yeah give it
a bit a little bit of a break and then
yeah there probably was like some slight
fatigue with with
um with Stargate we just said goodbye to
sgu1
Stargate Atlantis was coming towards its
final season and then or the final
episode and then we've got SGU
and it was massively different for one
so it was we were mourning the loss of
essentially sg1 and SGA
um
so yeah there probably wasn't fatigue
there
we'll stalk at you just
it's too different
was that part of the problem Aaron
um probably part of it but I I there's
the fatigue argument is being made
in the um
comic book movie genre too
yeah and that's been being kicked back
forth is there a comic book content
fatigue happening is that why Marvel's
falling off
no the fatigue is not with
VIP the fatigue is with the quality of
the content that that IP has been
putting out lately
it's not an IP problem it's a quality
problem
Marvel just had phase four that's why
they're in trouble
Star Trek had Discovery divisive
um stranger worlds I hear decent what's
the one that came out in between those
two
the first two seasons of Picard were
very unpopular yeah Picard was pretty
divisive I enjoyed that a lot of people
didn't
um
Enterprise is Enterprise one of the new
ones or is that the Scott Bakula one
Engine prices
there's a discovery stranger word wasn't
there a third one strange new odds
besides that one
now because you know you got the
cartoons so you've got lower decks and
um Prodigy
Star Trek show yeah I love it but the
main point being it's it's not IP
fatigue I don't think people had I don't
think people had Stargate fatigue I
think
I think most of it was the audience was
just shocked by the sudden tonal shift
plus it's Stu started off slow I think
if they'd have given it the third season
and allowed that to happen SGU probably
would have gone five or six I still
think SGU started off with a bang the
first two episodes are great but then it
went into like four or five episodes
when it was all about getting water and
getting fit and you know it was always
quite procedural and it was just a bit
boring by the end of the first season it
was picking up and second season sort of
a bit but I actually think that it just
wasn't fun and I just think it was I
think it was two different
sd1 and SGA were super fun I think that
was a lot that was probably one of the
biggest draws is because they knew how
to mix the right amount of action the
right amount of character uh interaction
and drama and the right ammonia
like they they had that formula down
Marvel used to have that formula down
and I think Stargate could get it back
if they got the right people handling it
again give me Mark Fergus as the
Stargate fighting
no I would agree with that
um do you think that Matt then so I I
think there are waves of things that
become popular you know like in music I
have rock music will become popular for
a few years and everyone starts
following it and you get Trends I think
you get Trends in TV as well I think
there are periods when sci-fi becomes
very popular I don't think Enterprise
was killed because it wasn't very good I
think it's good just because people just
weren't interested in sci-fi for a bit I
actually think there was a a massive
increase in like reality TV and that's
what everyone wanted to watch yeah and
it just it just if that was and it maybe
it wasn't as good as the previous stuff
but but it was good enough and actually
I did have quite good viewing figures I
think it actually got canceled because
TV Executives went reality TV is much
cheaper than this Star Trek
to make let's just do another series of
big brother it's much cheaper
um but do you think that's part of the
problem and that maybe we're at risk of
seeing that again because maybe it's
just
we're seeing a move away from streaming
all the big money that streaming
services were spending and now they're
realizing they're going to cut their
budgets is sci-fi an expensive luxury
it is expensive but it's
you're always going to have your core
audience and I think as long as they
enjoy it
um
and they share it it could
lead to a Resurgence in in sci-fi
because it's the same with
um
I don't know I'm going to take it take
it from the example of of a YouTuber
let's imagine
PewDiePie stopped uploading for like
five years
right
this analogy might not work but I think
it will let's imagine let's see if a
PewDiePie doesn't upload for five years
when he's when he uploads five years
later his core audience to people that
really loved PewDiePie are going to
watch that
and then that's gonna spiral into oh my
God PewDiePie's back it's gonna it's
like a spider web of people going have
you seen this video have you seen this
video have you seen this video have you
seen this video
the viral effect kind of thing yeah and
I'm not saying that's going to happen
with sci-fi but it could
if it was good it was really good it
could happen
well that that's the Crux really it's
like there's so much stuff out there for
us to consume
I mean even Justin even just in like one
genre
whether it's sci-fi or what have you
there's just so many options out there
if you're not making something
really good that's going to grab people
right off the bat you're screwed that's
just all there is to it you're just
gonna fade off into the
internet
ether and just float around out there
maybe get snagged by somebody here and
there but as far as achieving any real
level of success that's not going to
happen
hmm I realize that analogy probably
doesn't work
um because everyone in the comment is
like who's PewDiePie
I mean most described person in the
world at one point okay if I said Mr
Beef let's say Mr B everyone knows Mr
Beast everyone knows
well I mean it's just yeah you do it be
the same thing with like even a popular
talk show host okay I'm retiring and
then all of a sudden they're like I'm
unretiring like like you say five years
later and they come back on a network
whether it's the one they started on or
not as soon as people hear that they're
coming back
same man united stop playing football
for techno money joking I'm not going to
go into that and that's not an analogy
that would work either because you know
um everyone would be happy
man united stop playing football
um
it's just it's like he wants me to
punish him he's taking an opportunity to
use his Vapor or [__] look at that look
at that
a little bit
taking advantage like that to you
[Laughter]
anyway so right
so now we've we've talked about all
these different possibilities and guys
get into the audience uh get into the
comments sorry Everyone's Watching at
the moment have we have we changed our
minds at all
could Stargate actually be a bigger
franchisor we haven't actually discussed
what bigger means but we can in a second
but could it be a bigger franchise in
five maybe ten years if
it comes back as we think I think Aaron
made a pretty good point earlier of
um
the internet being in this infancy back
back then and now things don't take
actually that long to
gain relevancy so obviously with my
example of stranger things
I think it could happen I think it
definitely could happen
and I would very much like it too
I'm going to change my answer I've got
is it I'm going to say yes
with
optimism with lots of optimism
and hope that it does
thank you so much for the
um uh what's it called
Super Chat yeah thank you so Star Trek
is this an enigmatic Universe with no
god-like aliens except the queue
Stargate had a theological sensitive
storyline and confront both demonic
false gods and beings who have ascended
you ever seen that Meme versus um it's
got the Star Trek thing and it's like we
shall not interfere we have our prime
directive and then it's got the SGU
character go we're here to kill your
garden give you guns
[Laughter]
um I always love that William yeah I I
do think there's
there's layers to Stargate that maybe
Star Trek doesn't have
yeah Star Trek was coming from a basic
theme of
um a political ideology of basically the
Federation is democracy and the Klingons
were communism
and that was kind of
everything else sprouted from that very
basic idea
um Utopia
I think Stargate was always the question
of what is a God
yeah uh with the Garwood
you could say they were Gods because
people worshiped them but but what does
that mean what is it just because
they're powerful
and then you've got the obviously the
the the introduction of the ascended
beings who for all intensive purposes
are Gods but say they're not
it's like we've got people who are not
not
physically god-like saying they are
people who are physically gone like
saying they're not so it's always what
is a God that I think that I think that
that pretty much sums up Stargate what
is a God I would say Star Trek is mostly
agnostic unless I misremember it wasn't
Star Trek five basically them journeying
to the edge of the Galaxy or the
universe or something to see beat God
face to face or some junk like that
there was a George
um there is so many problems with Star
Trek 5 I don't even know where to begin
foreign
yeah they went to the galactic center ah
okay which was a big barrier and then
yes they found God and then
um William Shatner Kirk says why does
God need a spaceship and then all hell
breaks loose and then they shoot God in
the face with a Klingon bird of prey
um and that's all good fine so yes they
go to find God but it's not really God
yeah but that movie is generally
considered by trekkies it's a big rude
and we pretend it was right it was right
we tried to pretend that I once went to
watch a um Star Trek
um marathon and it was when Star Trek
Nemesis came out so it was at the cinema
and it started at like eight o'clock at
night and went through I saw about three
in the Morning Star Trek five hit and I
was just like well I can have a nap now
I'm totally with you on that I've I've
that movie is terrible music that movie
for me is Star Trek's love and thunder
like I hate that movie
I hate Star Trek five I've only ever
watched once I'll only ever watch it
once same thing with love and thunder
it's actually got a really good start
the bit on the mountain and everything I
really like the star and sequence I
thought it was really good bringing them
characters together like that family
sort of feel and there's a couple of
funny bits in the film but generally
it's not a good movie
ohura dancing on the Dune and stuff it's
just a bit embarrassing it was like oh
God but then they came back with
Undiscovered Country yes this is
probably the best Star Trek movie it's
my favorite
but it's because it was the first I
stuck out of school to go watch it in
the cinema
so mine is still mine is still the
cliche Wrath of Khan that's that I love
that movie we're at the kind is the best
oh my God
[Laughter]
well Aaron have you have we I mean you
said you think it could do you agree
that you still think it could oh for
sure I told yeah I have I have no reason
to change my mind after this
conversation whatsoever if anything well
I changed Matt's mind
come to us Matthew
um
like I said there's conditions they need
they need the Right leader first of all
like if
I don't know who else would be good
other than Fergus so at this point in
time I'm inclined to see if they don't
get Fergus
it's probably not gonna be great
um
so I think that's the biggest thing they
need they need the right person to lead
it and then they need a good PR team and
it could explode so easily yeah they
cannot make the mistakes they made with
rings of power nope
is going to come down to PR
initially
well if because they are really if they
are if they genuinely do do a cinematic
movie
I'm not sure it's a great idea but if
that's what they do
um and and the more I hear the more I
think that is very likely
um even though I'm not sure the
decisions actually finally been made but
um
I think they really are putting all
their eggs in that basket they really
are like taking a risk
and from our point of view we want a
franchise to succeed they're just they
might just be thinking it's kind of a
movie but I do hear that they have
realistic expectations of what that
movie would do
um but that was coming from I I spoke to
somebody that worked in actually was in
PR
at MGM they don't work there anymore but
they used to work there and they said
that when we were talking about a movie
it was on the understanding that this if
this movie breaks it it's an advert for
the series basically yes as long as they
don't expect a runaway success but that
but that was the sort of there's
realistic expectations so and if that
holds true and nobody sort of freaks out
if it just breaks even
then but you know what executives are
like they're not exactly
um you know focused of times I I always
think that some breaks even they've got
a free advert
yeah basically but that's not how they
think
um and I always think like a room full
of
um TV Executives is like a bag full of
cats
and
they make idiotic decisions at times
because they panic because any any
business is the same but I'm hoping they
have a plan cinematic movie immediately
followed by a series that is connected
to that movie and then an expanded
franchise which will have been mapped
out by Mark Fergus hopefully and that
they will stick to that plan even if the
movie only breaks even
it's quite interesting comment
it's going to move forward with a new
Target they need to get Amanda Tapping
involved at created level and make a
Jonathan Frakes of this time I would 100
agree with you and I have heard rumors
multiple times initially the Brad Wright
was desperate to bring Amanda Tapping on
and they were talking about directing
I did hear rumors before Mark Fergus got
involved that they did have
conversations about Man attacking
potentially show running
and that is because she's never actually
shown but she's executive produced two
or three different series
um and she pretty much show her in that
Sanctuary that was her baby
um I think if they get Amanda and the
rumor is that they've already got a
verbal agreement with Amanda Tapping to
return to the show when it happens and
again
yes they did and Cake
um and and but if they bring Amanda
Tapping in I think it's going to be on
something she's going to be directing
and she's going to be behind behind the
screens as well she might not but in
theory we still don't have a showrunner
Mark Fergus won't necessarily showrun
apparently that's what he would like to
do but he's never done it
um he's never even been he's been
executive producer and he's developed
he's very good at developing TV shows
we still need that Kevin fire now it's
in theory Mark Fergus is that guy he's
the he's the story guy I was thinking
almost a little bit like Warner Brothers
James they brought James Bond in as the
creative guy and that Mark Fergus but
they knew they also needed a manager
yeah we don't know who that's going to
be yet or it could have been that um
we had that uh what's his name Naran
Shankar and was that his name apparently
known Sankar did have a meeting with
somebody at um MGM about an undisclosed
sci-fi project
um two to three weeks ago
we don't necessarily know what that is
but if Mark Fergus is saying look I
don't think I can do this I want I need
somebody to work alongside I've worked
along now I've worked for Narron before
he's not actually doing anything at the
moment
um
that maybe they're thinking you've
worked together before but we're
completely speculating on that we don't
know for sure we know the meeting
happened that's all yeah
has any possibility
has anyone giving you any any indication
of what uh the Cinematic budget would
look like I'll park anything
we had initial figures but I think they
probably changed by now and yeah I think
we know
that I heard talk of around 90 million
okay
um but that wouldn't include Absa but
that is kind of based on very initial
and I think how long ago was that Matt
six months
about that yeah
I just wanted a number beginning of the
year for calculations and then
apparently Mark and then for the budgets
for TV series Mark Fergus was asking for
10 million an episode and Amazon was
pushing for five million episodes oh
yeah yeah that's one of the things so
they have been initial conversations
about budget but I think it's only the
the budget conversations as far as I'm
aware have only been in times of Mark
Fergus is sort of saying look I'm going
to develop this but I need I need a
rough idea of what I can spend because
then I do I think big do I think small
you know what I mean so it's sort of
like look if I've only got 50 million
this is gonna have to be character
driven if I've got 150 million I can go
I can have spaceships and I mean lots of
different I can go in lots of different
worlds and stuff so what are we looking
at right I was just curious about the
Cinematic budget just because
um like even if it's say 100 million
it's easier math that means they'd only
need to make 300 to break even
well yeah well basically one and a half
times your budget is what you need to
cover
you know operating cost plus marketing
generally it's around they think a
PR budget a marketing budget around 50
to 60 million is is generally what a
cinematic Movie costs depending on
um like Avatar was way more
um and other movies are obviously way
less but I mean for me I think why did
they bother spending all that money on
Avatar like people would were not going
to notice
you know it's just stupid I don't know
why they bothered but um
but if we get that sort of 90 million
Mark that is roughly what
a sort of a B level DC movie cost it's
roughly what that girl cost yeah at the
point where they pulled it
um
so I I think that's reasonable budget we
do know that Amazon are planning to
spend roughly 1 to 1.5 billion dollars a
year on
um cinematic movies that's been released
that we know that is true and that that
is supposed to be five to six movies a
year
so we can you can do this
it's I think it's about 300 million per
wait whatever two to three hundred
million
but we don't know
five movies yeah like three million 300.
we don't know if that's just production
money or full budget but if we were
looking at a 90 million move if we would
be looking at about 130 million total
budget ish
yep so we have 300 mil we'll cover all
of that and allow you some profit too so
yeah based on and even if it if it's the
biggest movie of the weekend when
Stargate does eventually come out you're
looking at maybe 100 million just in
America
um and that's that doesn't have to be a
runaway success to get to make that sort
of money and then you've got the
worldwide thing because I mean I would
argue Stargate is more popular
internationally you've got a massive
European audience yeah so they're going
to get them to sell at least
that at least double their home money so
I I think this is if they if they aim
for something like 150 million it'll
it'll it'll make that that's cinematic
alone yeah I think without too much
without really having to be a runaway
success
yeah I don't I don't yeah I don't think
yeah I think the movie would probably
definitely break even so they'll get
their free two-hour uh commercial for it
for sure I'm not too worried about that
and if and if it really blows over they
make all kinds of money off it they'll
be yeah and they don't have to spend
loads of money on Advertising because
well they're
so yeah YouTube will go [__] crazy
that's one of the things that kills me
about Disney is they constantly
copyright
strike and claim people left and right
and all those people are doing is trying
to watch their trailer they're they're
gonna they're copyright striking their
free advertising it's what they're doing
freaking idiots 100 right thank you so
much guys I think we have covered that
one a brilliant Aaron you've thought of
them this little
um storyline today so thank you so much
and it made for a brilliant chat so
thank you so so much Matt you you turned
up
Harris didn't I did I did turn up
I saw the thumbnail and I was like he
hasn't responded
he hasn't been online either so I think
Harris is sleeping
I wonder if Harris had a very good night
last night
so um guys thanks everybody in the
audience and the in the comments has
been absolutely fantastic thank you so
so much we get really great views every
time we talk about Stargate we get you
guys turn up and it's amazing thank you
so much so we will be back with you next
week no idea what we're going to be
talking about but we'll talk about
something and
let's hope that you know we have
something interesting so bye-bye guys
see you later
[Music]